Spurgeon back to their lineup here tonight
there's a shot to the point by Dalene pass
save made by gusterson Middleton will poke
it to the corner taken back by Thompson
Dalene Skinner one timer and a pat save 12
seconds to go the man Advantage no score just
underway KBS over on the far wall Puck comes to
petka with a shot and that is blocker away and
petka of course having a nice start to the
season firing pucks tried to drag that shot
through backhander side of the net looking for
cousins first attemp to Center off the back of
the net Skinner puts it in front it goes up always
interesting to watch the growth of a player in the
National Hockey League particular go tenders Levi
there sensing has to hold on to that get a little
reset for his group there's a pat save again as
Minnesota's had a Marcus Johansson drops it off
and he'll get it back on the board Middleton
creeping down slides it through and a backand
on goal there by baly is stopped to the rebound
on the wall Sabers get it to the line but not
out it's kept in by Baldi for the Minnesota Wild
watch baly here 12 on this one on the back hand
Levi makes a save there Faber a back check there
by JJ petka wild continue on anyway shot by Faber
at the point save made by Levi twice right on the
doorstep and this one is going to be credited to
Har 77 right on the left side of the net there he
is and zukar gets the opportunity right there but
you got to keep them second guessing themselves
here zukar from the near circle with a shot and
The Rebound with ericon getting a whack or two
out it is smothered by Levi Levi makes the save
here it is zukar firing this in he's not able
to handle there's one and just as he's coming
across with the second one Levi is able to get
that glove on top of him but you see he gets a
stick down in front and heuse 33 seconds seconds
to go in the penalty to JJ petka and a scoreless
first and here's a turnover zus Genson with a
partial break Genson back head save by juson
Zam GE great here picks this one off and he's Off
to the Races here he is he hits what 20 mph at top
speeden takes a look sees some room on that left
side of the ice now the Sabers with three on the
attack nice carry here by middle stat to the net
save by gusterson he wasn't sure where that one
went and here's middle stat again pulling up
firing man in front throwing his in across the
line to the right side Middleton on H swept to
the front of the net cs's got a piece of it but
it comes back on the wall power sends it across
[Music] SC Henry Yi are you with the blast and
the Sabers take the onling lead with 158 remaining
in Period number one but what the Sabers have been
able to do the last few minutes is just create
havoc in the offensive zone they're taking the
pucks to the net they're winning the battles
and they're really getting Minnesota running
around here quite a bit you see that shot from
the point by Henry yogar you got cousins there
you got Thompson in front it sneaks right past
Thompson and it's going to enter to the net now
Henson plays it to the wall ziper pully fire post
oh Deon Levi did not get there he made the effort
but Minnesota on the power play as capris off ties
the game at one with 29.9 seconds remaining in the
period and this finally got it here's Baldi
he slides it across the K off right here and
there when this happens and it's a perfect
pass and there's a perfect execution on the
shot ran Johnson he is not shy of being part of
the game here Rossy on a two-on one the turn pass
to the back head stop by Levi what a save oh
my Levi keeps this in a 1-1 game comp period
to early four shots already Minnesota has got on
him right here two on one coming in and on the
back hand he's able to get that pad out and just
fall it across and just get a piece of it with pad
glove and deflect it up and over but sab's got to
be careful here letting guys in behind Rossy and
Capri off the hash marks right wing side takes a
return pass off puck Movement by Baldi Capri off
back to Baldi save made by Levi blocker punching
that one away on this big kill there was a shot
he's able to get the Blocker on that one gets it
out of the way throws it all over in the other
far side baly right there b pass by the wild Z
corello whips that one across back to the near
side and that one off the side of the post and
I'll tell you what the pad Levi might have been
there anyway minota Force back on their own end
zcar plays it on the boards Middleton's going to
turn this one over great chance for Dylan cousins
his mask on there in the middle of the ice there's
a quick opportunity he's got a Ryan Johnson will
play to the wing for Greenway Middle stat try to
backhand that one across the line the wild pick
it off and it's a potential two-on-one here for
Minnesota Rossy without the puck and the shot on
goal there by Brody is stopped saber just kind of
backed in just a little too much you got to be
challenging a little bit more one guy's got to
come across and challenge a little bit the the
offside D is taking that man driving through
here's a chance for Skinner now catching up to
the puck on a breakway Skinner de [Applause]
scor but good pressure here kerop not able
to get able to get that and just skner picks
it up in motion and able to get separation
and when he does he just puts a quick little
move you see how he got back on his heels and
his skates and changed Direction real quick as
soon as he started making the move towards
the net got right on the heels right there
now it's Skinner back the other way Skinner
with three seconds takes the shot rebound
right in front and off the post at the floor
by Jeff Skinner oh he was flying there in the
latter stages of that period for the saber
staff when it comes to people being healthy
again and wanting back in the lineup those
33 has looked really good yeah he's earned
the opportunity and he's earning every second
he's on the ice and Donnie Granado's put him
in really important situations and he's handled
him great here's Thompson from Skinner in from
SC JJ
PKA now p is going to collect this ship with a
nice pass coming out the Zone T Thompson right
here with Skinner the two of them given go
coming down the wall and the big thing is
Thompson never lost any momentum taking this
Puck down low and everybody's staring at those
two guys Skinner and Thompson at JJ PK is able
to W his way Eric Johnson try to move it past
Felino and Middleton in behind the net there's
maroon with a HP from behind on clipped and the
puff comes in front save by dein Levi was going
on but watch this save right here on Eric Z as
Levi gets that right pad out 35 seconds to go
on the kill here for buffalo good pressure on
the wall by kyoso the drop P that bie in on the
play now this is capriso f post one timer scores
Eric s parked over at that Far Side gets the power
play goal with 733 remaining in the third it's 3-2
Buffalo the power play quick pass across and he
gets himself set up on that offside just right
just north of the goal line his bottom foot's
literally onit her across it as he comes across
and once again I see when that pass comes across
trying to send it down the wall and he does here's
Casey midd coming off the wall again midd stat
to the front of the net and a blocker save by
gustavson he'll play it ahead Minnesota to Center
Ice zarella left side to the net oh what a save by
Levi he got over to that far post here once again
this zuk carala takes this with to that one over
in the corner Wild win the draw fan on the first
shot it's off the [Applause] post once again made
some big saves at crucial times and here at the
end he had to make a couple that one's going to go
right off the post as Spurgeon takes the shot but
you just see him backhander by Baldi to the net
with two seconds Capri off save by Levi the force
was with them tonight and the Sabers went it 3
to2